now we're going through this really
quickly
right 10 of 10
inverse okay again without having to put
in values okay
what kinds of things are you going to
expect
out of this well when we did uh sine of
sine inverse we just got a line okay
when we did cause a compliment because
it means we got the same line
okay they were both restricted right
because
um this was restricted and this was
restricted
okay so what's the restriction on tan
inverse of x
what's the domain restriction
oh it's not inclusive right and it's
minus it it just goes for all real bonds
right so therefore you know since
since this restriction here locked us in
here minus one and one
right seeing as there's no x restriction
on tan
inverse of x we ought to expect that it
would not have an x restriction for
the whole thing right and you can go
ahead you can test out some values sure
enough
it's y equals x but this time it's just
y equals x
okay it's equal to x for all real values
of x
okay all right
now last one tan
inverse of tan
hmm now there is a restriction on this
one right
what's the um domain restriction on
this function 10x what did we choose it
is now not inclusive minus python 2.
yeah that's right it's very
similar to sine but not quite sorry sine
inverse okay so i'm not going to get
those endpoints
so i'm going to get that same kind of
shape like this
but i'm not having those endpoints
now what happens i am actually going to
get you to um take your calculators back
out again and give this a go okay
if i'm at pi on two here at minus
pi on two okay so i'm trying to
determine what happens
over here right before with cos and with
sign we've got this bouncing thing
okay so let's try a value let's try
another like saying if this is pi on two
let's try pi what value do you get when
you say tan inverse of tan
now that's interesting at least at the
moment it looks like
it could be doing the same thing that
sign was doing right it looks like it
could be doing this
how would you know if it did that or not
yeah let's try another one what value
looks like it would be useful to us here
well if we if we're testing between here
right that's um between pi of two and pi
is three times four right so
what's tan inverse of tan three pi
four
now you're probably going to get some
weird number right and that's because
everything's in terms of radians right
so can anyone work out what it's
actually equal to
you might want to multiply by something
is it positive or negative
it's negative isn't it right it's
negative right um
so we're in trouble at least for this
you know hypothesis says this proposal
it clearly can't go through here because
it's actually down here okay
so i if i remember right it should be um
minus pi on four i think
anyone want to verify that you can
multiply before you get three four yeah
okay
all right so i'm here
[Music]
where do you think this is going can we
test another value that'll be you know
they'll give us something useful
what might you test maybe maybe five pi
and four
on the other side okay what are you
going to get
what would you guess
you're getting you're getting the the
positive version of that right you're
getting part four
okay so what does it look like it's
doing it looks like it's doing this
right um and tan
is periodic right so you're probably
gonna expect the same kind of shape
to repeat over and over again so i've
got zero here
that would make this minus pi there's pi
and it goes on and on and on
it's got all these holes in it why does
it have so many holes because
and so on they correspond to the
asymptotes of tan x
right again the domain of this guy this
inside function if you like
it defines the domain of the whole lot
right so
tan x exists everywhere except for minus
point two pi over two
uh three pi two and so on okay so that's
why we have those holes
and that's what it looks like okay